good morning afternoon evening you know
everyone depending on where you are uh I
am Shashank Sher and I am founder of AI
ordinate we are you know a startup
building um um an nlm Ops platform
focused on reducing cost and latency and
enhance you know the quality of um um LM
applications and systems now uh what
we're uh also doing uh you know um is
putting significant focus on enhancing
you know the security of large language
models right and our efforts involve
addressing you know key aspects uh uh to
ensure the robustness and safety of you
know um um uh the large language models
in various applications and
environments uh I have more than 16
years of experience in artificial
intelligence machine learning uh deep
learning right and I have worked in
multi multiple last tech companies
including you know Amazon uh VMware
Flipkart Target among others right uh
today uh uh as conr said right the topic
of my presentation is llms beyond the
hype right a practical journey to scale
now the world of llm you know has grown
a lot right in in in last one year right
one year or so right and um it has given
us you know many choices for creating
and analyzing text right uh uh uh you
know but using these powerful
models can can turn out to be very very
costly right and in my talk today I will
carefully look at ways to find a good
balance making uh uh you know llm
systems cheaper um um also making them
work better uh you know that is you know
improving quality uh uh and also making
them faster right so decreasing the
latency now uh what I will also do is
delve into uh the anatomy of llm based
applications and we'll talk about some
practical strategies of deploying you
know large language models at
scale so uh you
know the you know uh if you see the
slide right the reference
architecture of llm applications right U
you know has begun uh emerging in last
few months right if you see uh you know
um there has been a lot of um um uh work
around this and the components leveraged
uh in a particular llm application is
you know function of uh of course the
use case right um U the requirements and
also you know uh the user uh preference
right uh and broadly uh these are uh the
six six key
components of a generic llm application
right now the first one of course is uh
you know choosing the right large
language model and it is very important
right because you know there are lot of
considerations around it right there are
a lot of factors around it you know one
key factor is of course the size of the
model right that you know how how many
parameters have been used to build that
model right U uh typically if you see
you know typically larger models will
give you better performance but uh in
recent times there has been you know
Advent of quite a few smaller models
which perform better than their larger
counterparts right um and you know since
cost and latency are other important
parameters to consider while choosing a
model you know um um uh you know usually
you know smaller models are cheaper and
faster uh and and hence right if you
have a smaller model which performs at
par a slightly you know
below par a larger model choosing the
smaller model is the right thing to do
right is is is more prudent given the
tradeoffs right uh the next crucial
parameter right um um you know while
choosing a large language model is of
course uh the licensing right uh you
know there are of course quite a few
open source model um and there are quite
a few behind an API right so if the
intent is to develop a commercial
medication it is important that you
ensure that you know the model that you
use has an you know API licensed for
commercial use right um and you know one
key consideration is that while some
llms may have tokenizers and embedding
models built within some others will
require you to run the steps yourself
right so um um also you know one more
thing right before you customize your
llm using techniques like you know uh
find tuning uh or in context learning or
or or rlf right uh it is important to
check how well and quickly and
consistently the model generates you
know your desired output right and this
is this is something which should check
before selecting you know uh the large
language model of choice right and uh
how you do that right how you measure
the model performance right uh of course
you'll have to do offline evaluations
and um um you know what what is offline
evaluations that offline evaluations are
set of tests to Major model performance
before you know interacting with human
right so um they do typical measurements
right like latency accuracy and also you
know contextual relevance of a model's
output right um and how it does is that
it asks the questions right um uh uh to
the model and and then you have either
correct or incorrect answer and based on
that it evaluates the model performance
right now uh in case there are not you
know ones or there are no ones or zero
so there's no correct incorrect but
ambiguous answers you know there is a
subset of test called incremental
scoring right um so what you can do is
score a model's output incrementally
correct rather than you know 100%
correct or incorrect you know
answers um so the second component is of
course prompt template right and uh uh
pretty popular right and prompt
engineering has evolved as a core
activity in llm application development
right there are several prompting
techniques right
um you know including you know zero shot
few shot uh chain of thoughts among
others right and uh uh they are being uh
leveraged widely um for for you know
making the uh whole system work better
right now the third component and is
very important one is the vector
database
right and then of course you know with
the popularity of lar language models
Vector database has also become quite
popular in recent you know time right uh
now where Vector databases help is with
retrieval augmented generation rag right
uh which is um you know I mean if you
put it simplistically right rag is
nothing but what it does is that um you
know the relevant
external information is first chunked
into uh you know blocks uh and by block
I mean you know sentences or paragraphs
and then tokenize right and then run
through an embedding model uh you know
and and these are then fed into a vector
database right uh you know so rag is
needed for use case which require access
to information that the you know large
language model or the large language
model that we have you have chosen has
not been trained on right so um and you
know Additionally you know the prompts
are also vectorized right uh and you
know what happens that once the prompts
are vectorized similarity search is
performed to retrieve you know relevant
entries from the database right and
these entries are then fed uh you know
alongside the original prompt you know
providing context needed to provide a
much coherent response right now you
know one thing I want to mention here is
that um you know this this thing also
AIDS in AI trust right and how it does
is that the large language model May
site which chunk it has used in its
response to counteract you know
potential hallucinations right so uh you
know and that's where Vector database
also plays an important role now there
are quite a few popular Vector databases
right uh pine cone chroma uh currant
right and and of course open source um
um you know Vector database is also
there right uh PG Vector right uh the
next component are the llm agents or you
can say llm agents and tools and they
are needed to perform actions Beyond
text generation typically llm if you use
um uh you know alone right uh you can
only do text generation so just limiting
the usage to to llms you know makes the
application quite constrained right and
hence agents you know play an important
role I mean they can do uh uh tasks like
web search math
calculation database lookup and others
right
now with agents there are you know quite
a few Frameworks that have also evolved
and you know um the idea
of you know combining reasoning right
alongside taking action uh uh using you
know uh tools uh has led to you know
emergence of a very popular framework
called react right so what react does
it's an iterative process right it
basically enters a loop of thinking
which action to take right and it then
takes that action uh observes the result
and then decides on the subsequent
action to take right and it does this in
an iterative fashion till the solution
is found right now this approach you
know of course you know
react framework and the approach
approach Associated you know has been
found to be outperforming Baseline llms
for sure right but one of the key
challenge with this is the you know um
performing you know uh uh you know um or
basically performing the evaluation or
evaluating uh you know the performance
of these system because it's pretty
challenging right so uh that's one key
challenge I'll touch up on that that in
a subsequent slide on this right now the
other major component is of course the
orchestrator right
um um and you know uh you can have um
you
know orchestrator because it helps you
create exraction on top of uh the
language model uh The Prompt template
data sources agents and tools right and
of course Lang chain and llama index are
quite popular and everyone knows uh you
know everyone know about that right now
uh one component this that I have missed
here is of course you know um llm
caching uh I think llm Cass is important
component for throughput improvement and
cost optimization and I will touch upon
that in a subsequent slide here I have
missed that right uh and of course the
last major component is the monitoring
module and as is the case with any Ops
engine or application monitoring key
metrics like performance you know
latency throughput um um CPU GPU memory
usage right uh uh drift potential drift
right all of these are very very
important now uh what you can do is that
you can develop your own monitoring
module right leveraging open source
tools like grafana uh but there are you
know some tools uh which gives you out
of box monitoring capabilities right um
Lang Smith is one the most popular one
of course is Seldon core V2 right uh
because with Selen core V2 you can also
detect potential buyers and it has also
got some um explainable AI Majors right
um um you know and and therefore I think
monitoring falls under the perview of
you know AI trust or responsible AI now
uh in this slide right I this I picked
up from one of the popular GitHub blog
right um now this is the visualization
depicting the anatomy of typical LM
application right now if you look at
this the components needed to build your
llm app uh can be know um roughly be
clubbed into three categories right um
if you see you know the uh you know the
first category right uh is that of
U user you know um U you know interface
right or basically you know user uh uh
UI or llm host right so if you see here
uh you know the user input is the you
know requires a UI and here is the UI
and then you have an llm API or llm and
app hosting platform so the UI and llm
app hosting platform can be in the
category of user input right the second
category can be you know input
enrichment and prompt optimization or
prompt construction tool right and here
uh you will have U uh you you know your
data source of course right and uh uh
embedding model right um and a vector
database right and of course you know
the prompt construction optimization
tools right and uh the data
filter the last category is as I said
earlier is of responsible AI tooling or
I would call it efficient and
responsible AI tooling and that includes
the cache so the llm cache um and uh um
you know the llm content classifier and
the T Tre right so you know these are
three rough categories now let's look at
you know each block in this diagram Now
llm API and host right so this
particular you know block so as far as
LM app is concerned right this that can
be hosted on frame as well as on cloud
right on Prime hosting U uh is much more
cost- effective but of course requires
some you know deep expertise to do it
end to end right uh the UI you know here
serves pin purpose right it is l by the
end user to send uh you know query um um
uh to to the llm and also you know acts
as a consumption layer you know where
you can retrieve the responses for a
given query right uh the vector database
we already talked about it you know uh
is the one where you can store
embeddings you know uh and then the data
filter uh is to ensure that llm isn't
processing any unauthorized data right
The Prompt optimization tool you know um
um you know helps prioritize you know
which content embeddings are most
relevant and also in which order those
embeddings should be organized right to
ensure that you know the llm produces
the most contextually relevant response
um llm cache which I said is very
important you know basically stores all
the responses I mean if you simplify it
it basically stores all the responses
and uh this is essential to you know
improve the throughput latency and cost
because if similar queries are being
asked that doesn't hit the API you know
but sends response from the Cass right
so that's where you can optimize for
cost as well as latency uh the content
classifier right or or you know filter
right content filter prevents the system
from you know responding uh uh you know
offensive or harmful content right and
lastly as I said Telemetry right
evaluates the efficacy of the app and
how well it is working with the actual
user you can have bunch of you know you
know monitors monitoring modules in
Telemetry service now in this slide I
want to talk about seven key patterns of
efficacious llm system application right
uh you know the first one is of course
evaluations and they are set of
measurements used to assess a model's
performance on a task right you know
they include U uh you know benchmark
data and metrics now one of the key
challenge you know of evaluating large
language models is that you know they
often produce open-ended outputs right
so there's no nothing you know like a
ground truth to compare it right so for
example if you've generated an essay or
let's say youve generated uh an email uh
leveraging an llm how you'll measure the
quality I mean there's no way you can
measure the quality because there's no
ground proof right now one potential way
and which is also being leveraged across
different areas is you know having human
annotators to the quality right but this
could become very very subjective right
because um um you know not only sub but
also very noisy and also you know it it
can turn out to be very slow and
expensive affair because you cannot have
human evaluating each and every output
that comes out of element you know a
portion of output that is coming out of
ANM system so you know while it is a
good method it might not be very uh it's
not very good I mean subjective and
noisy but in some cases it might turn
out to be good method but it's not very
efficient method right now one potential
way is to Benchmark against the best
available individual llm right so um you
see in today's world GPD 4 uh I just
using a rule of thumb which is not 100%
correct but if you say that a model with
maximum parameters uh you know uh is the
best individual I mean gp4 wins the race
so you can you know leverage gp4 for
bunch marking and evaluation right now
the next one is of course Rag and as I
already mentioned it is a technique that
combines you know llms with you know
document retrieval to generate outputs
that incorporate recent and you know
external knowledge right now Rags work
by first you know retrieving uh relevant
documents from a large Corpus based on
the input query or context and then
feeding the retrieved documents as
additional context to the LM generation
right now um you know there are several
ways in which rack can be done better
right I mean of course there is uh you
know using the right embeddings for the
right problems you can also um you know
um uh uh you know do quantization right
using scalar or binary quantization um
on your vector store right to improve
the latency and throughput on your
vector store but for that you know your
vector store should support s
quantization and then you know reranking
you know also a way to you know improve
rack signicantly uh fine tuning right is
the process of you know taking a
pre-train model and further defining it
on a specific task and you know to get
better at a specific task and that's
also a method casing I already discussed
right it's essential for reducing
latency and cost um you know guard rails
uh you know are set of rules or
constraints that ensure that quality is
of good quality and is reliable right so
what it does is that it prevents error
and failures and also enforce standards
and expectations right and uh defensive
ux right is more of a design principle
right right that you know um anticipates
and manages any adversarial events while
you are interacting you know while while
a user interaction is happening right so
things like hallucinations inaccuracies
can be anticipated and then you know um
kind of mitigated or or you know managed
right so these are basically set of
guidelines for human AI interaction and
that can happen across the user Journey
right so it can be uh before the
interaction happens during the
interaction when something goes wrong as
well as over time right and the last
pattern is of course collecting user
feedback and very essential right
because this is essential for learning
the preferen of user and contributes to
you know building the evaluation
mechanism the evaluation of the fine
tuning the guard ra right it also helps
us improve our models by learning what
users like dislike and you know their
preferences now U this is you know the
graph depicting LM patterns across the
AIS of data to user and defensive to
offensive right now uh if you see here
you know um um fine-tuning and retrial
augmented generation with the generators
are high on uh improving performance so
if you want to improve performance you
can do uh these right whereas uh cing
and guard rails or basically collecting
user feedback and defensive ux are high
on user experience right or or or or you
know overall us engagement uh casing and
Gage are mediators right and they are
kind of U uh uh they kind of you know
help you reduce the cost uh significant
uh um and then you know evaluation is
necessary to ensure that you know um
your output you know your performance of
the system is optimal right and you know
data fly whe is the process of
continuous data collection and help
improve the model and you know um um
leads to better user experience and
that's where you know you have data fly
will uh you know very well as well
now you
know if you see let me you know quickly
discuss some of the key challenges with
llm deployment especially in an
Enterprise setup right now accuracy and
quality of output is a key challenge
right especially when you have varied
context and large number of use cases uh
generalist models tend to achieve lower
accuracy on a specialist task right so
accuracy is definitely a key challenge
uh the Second Challenge is that of cost
right as I said you know the best
individual llm um you know let's say
gbd4 is quite costly and you know there
are uh
you know the other cloud-based models
are also costly and Enterprise find it
difficult to justify you know Roi
through you know if they do the cost
benefit analysis you know currently on
you know the llm models that are
available right now latency is another
big challenge right and uh can affect
the your experience as well as efficacy
of llm you know uh system right uh uh
the other key challenges right are of
course scaling prompt engineering uh you
know because uh you know uh that is
handling you know ambiguous output
format inconsistency usual experience
right and optimization pattern right
that is you know prompting versus fine
tuning
now here what I'm doing is I'm
recommending an approach and this is
inspired by Fugal GPT but there are few
additional elements to it right for
deploying you know large language models
at scale right with lower cost higher
quality right uh uh you know and reduce
latency now most current deployments
leverage you know and individual llm so
one llm right and you know then bunch of
things are done on top of it right now
the recommended approach basically
entails right leveraging multiple LMS
right along with bunch of uh techniques
which are you know kind of acronymed
here PSA llma R Ruf and llmc uh you know
along with you know uh prompting
techniques right to achieve you know
substantial uh efficacy or efficiency
gains I would say right
now uh PSA as you see in the last slide
refers to prompt selection and
adaptation and basically involves
identifying and selecting effective you
know uh when I say effective you know
often shorter prompts to save cost right
uh uh you know some of the techniques
within you know uh PSA are prompt
shortening you know selecting uh most
effective uh and sest prompt as I said
earlier right D duplicating the queries
right or prompts based on similarity so
uh not not I mean based on some
similarity score and then query can can
concatenation right to aggregate
multiple queries to share prompts uh
llma refers to LM approximation and what
it does is that it aims to create
simpler and cheaper llm that can match
the performance of a more powerful right
uh uh but expensive you know model out
there right now in tactical terms right
this could involve uh choosing a less
expensive model that has been shown to
perform well on a particular type of
task right um um you know and then
um um you
know so for example you know and then
then then then basically you know um you
are you can also do you know completion
cing right comption cing is nothing but
uh the cing that I talked about right uh
model fine tuning and model evaluations
are also within llm approximation uh you
know and then Ruf is request hedging
basis user feedback and this is very
important and this is a technique which
initiates so in this technique what it
what happens is that the streaming
response right is initiated using the
fastest model right and then what you do
is you edit the output on the UI you
want a better but slower model response
right now request heading can also be
done you know not only based on uh uh uh
the response on speed or or based on
latency but uh to save cost by
leveraging user feedback right so if a
user is happy right with the output of a
you know faster a smaller model you can
send a smaller portion of your request
to the best individual LM right uh and
you know more uh request can be sent to
the smaller model right and this also
improves you
know uh this this will also improve or
this will help you improve the quality
of your system over time because what
you can do is that you can do your
evaluation of your responses to user
right leveraging best individual LM
because you're still sending some
portion of your request to the best
individual llm uh llm cascading right is
a popular concept uh because of fugal
gbd and what it does is that it
basically focuses on you know adaptively
choosing which large language models to
use for different queries right now in
Practical terms this could mean using a
less expensive model for simpler queries
and reserving the more expensive models
for more complex queries right uh now
what you are doing uh uh uh by doing
this is you are only paying for the more
expensive resources when you really need
them right now in this module uh you
know there is a linear regression based
scoring function generator which
generates a reliability score given a
query and a response right and there is
a llm router which routes the query to a
particular llm to optimize for cost
latency and quality uh now uh uh you
know uh in interest of time I'll just
I'll just run through it fast when it
comes to optimizing resources and cost
right llm compression techniques right
are of utmost importance right uh I will
not go into each of these right uh uh
now when it comes to model compression
techniques
right they are critical to shrink the
llms making them viable right for low
resources devices and reduce ing you
know of course their um uh um cost and
also environmental footprint right now
here's a taxonomy of different
compression methods right there is
pruning knowledge distillation low rank
factorization and quantization now in
the interest of time I will not go
through each of these but quickly
discuss quantization as it is the most
important compression technique and it
is vital for on prame MMS now the most
effective way for saving long-term cost
uh is to have on lens now if you see
here uh you know a simple quantization
helps compress a large model right large
language model like Lama 2 right uh 7
billion 13 billion 70 billion parameters
we almost 3 to 4X so 138 GB original
size fp6 model you know leveraging you
know llama CBP quantization method you
know has decreased the size to 40.7 GB
and it's very important uh method see
you know one of the ways to decrease the
cost on longer ter is of course
leveraging on primens right and for that
I think quantization is very much
important you can do quantization for
you know for enabling inference on CPU
as well so if you see gml right llamas.
CBP is one part of one one way of gml
right is the way to do quantization for
inference some CPU and these are
different you know methods of
quantization so I think pretty much that
uh